[Musique]
vous
pas ces nouvelles instit vous départ est
ce que vous avez dit à punir des lèvres
qu'il avait rien fait alors qu'il
n'avait rien fait à bien son prénom
ça tombe bien parce que j'ai pas fait un
exercice qu'on devait faire pour
aujourd'hui complètement marteau la
maîtrise il faut vraiment que tu arrêtes
faire des bêtises et une dernière chance
topo mon patron sera là tu te tient à
carreau
via le plaisir de vous accueillir dans
ce nouveau lieu de culture
[Applaudissements]
alors ça j'aime bien ça c'est marrant ça
ils adorent tout il me faut un coupable
mais c'est pas moi on ne fait pas de
bêtises dans un musée tu as complètement
bien fait mon poto à bas taux va pas
aimer on est obligé de mettre en pension
l'enfant obéi et l'enfant avance j'ai
besoin d'un copain intelligents ici je
démonte pas mon innocence je vais
travailler en interne en fait jamais les
aubes et aymeric de toute ma vie
non mais tu as on s'habitue très vite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as encore fabriquée
zéro plus zéro tête et à toutes